on my channel think media we are getting
3 500 views every 60 minutes
it's like i am right now at this moment
actually getting to hang out with you at
this really cool event
and at the same time i have duplicated
myself i it's like it's my clone army of
sean robots that are on the internet
doing 3 500 sales calls that are doing 3
500 meetings and i'm able to talk to
people at scale using the power of the
youtube algorithm
now again let's just take that down to
10 350 people one percent 35 people
every hour let's take it to one day 35
people a day watch your content friends
on the other side of implementing this
information we're about to learn you'll
be able to do this
[Music]
did you know that only nine percent of
businesses are using youtube to grow
their business and over 30 percent of
people are coming to youtube looking for
answers to their problems business
owners you need to be on
youtube and in today's episode sean's
going to be sharing a talk that he did
in florida to a room full of financial
advisors now i know you probably
listened to this podcast for all
different types of reasons but i really
wanted to bring this episode to you
because i believe that the business
owners that understand content creation
are going to be the business owners of
the future my name is heather torres and
i'm the host of the think media podcast
the number one podcast to help you grow
your youtube channel and then turn your
youtube channel into a high impact and a
high profit online business now today's
episode is brought to you by our grow
with video live conference i'll tell you
more about that in just a minute but if
you're new to this podcast i want to
welcome you and say thank you for being
here listening today and if you want to
share this out with a friend who is a
business owner wants to get into
business or you know should be doing
content creation this is going to be the
episode for them we're talking all about
how to get clients and grow your youtube
channel and this will be that episode
for them
well today sean's going to be jumping
into this and then afterwards i'm gonna
conclude with just telling you a little
bit about how you can get access to our
business day at grow with video live
let's jump into sean's presentation in
florida for business owners
[Music]
my name's sean and i'm super fired up
today to talk to you about the power of
using youtube to grow your businesses
we're going to be talking about how to
get clients build your authority and
grow your financial service business
with youtube and uh super grateful i
flew here all the way from seattle
washington
across country and so it's good to see
you orlando it's good to see you made it
here i know a lot of drama in the
airport on my way here and so i'm just
grateful to be with you hey if you're
taking notes in this session we're going
to be learning three reasons youtube
rocks for financial services
how to get leads with youtube and five
smart ideas
for growing your financial service
business with youtube and a whole lot
more but did you know that officially
more than half of the people on planet
earth are on social media now
not more than half of the people on the
internet actually more than half of
humans are on social platforms
accessible on the other side of a tablet
a phone a computer a smart tv
reachable by you when it comes to
helping them with their finances and why
youtube specifically though you know
because there's so many different
marketing opportunities right now
there's so many things you're already
doing in fact you might be thinking yeah
it sounds cool would love to do youtube
but like i'm already busy i already got
a lot a lot of stuff to do well why
youtube specifically well right now
there's over 2.3 billion monthly active
users on youtube that are actually
logged in every month with a gmail
account
so those watching that's even more than
that what's fascinating is if you think
about especially reaching baby boomers
uh that many people are watching youtube
without a gmail account but they just
log in from their ip you know they just
log in i mean for their computer their
their smart tv to start watching and
your content can start reaching them in
fact seven out of ten baby boomers are
already on youtube
more gen x
so this isn't like is this going to be
happening for the audience you want to
reach it already is happening
it's exciting and uh social media and
live streaming has only been accelerated
by the pandemic that we've been going
through i just had christmas uh i'm sure
you you celebrated as well merry
christmas and so i was home with family
in seattle and uh we're hanging out and
it was super weird because at my mom and
step dad in their 70s began to tell me
about their
favorite youtubers they've been watching
i felt like i was in the twilight zone i
was like excuse me what mom
and it just and i started to realize
that even this year their adoption
of youtube social media is was
accelerated with lockdowns and with
people becoming more comfortable
accessing these
platforms but one of the things that i
think is most significant and why it's
important that we go all in to grow our
businesses with youtube is because
youtube is the second largest search
engine in the world
second to google and owned by google
youtube is accessed by people with
questions and people that are trying to
solve problems
what this means
is that you can create a youtube video
one time
upload it on youtube but that it could
continue to be accessed for weeks
months and even years to come
you know i have videos that are
literally 10 years old now i didn't know
it at the time but i've been able to
live the experience of posting them on
youtube
figuring out strategies that work to
keep them being seen which you'll learn
today
that are still getting views this year
and it kind of reminds me of a concept
that you're an expert at already
and it's compound interest right i mean
albert einstein said it was the eighth
wonder of the world benjamin franklin
said
money makes money and the money that
makes money makes money and what's the
power of compound interest it's the fact
that it starts small and it seems
insignificant but if you're consistent
with it over time it begins to compound
and the truth is we can actually relate
youtube to that maybe not in the same
way but is this going to take energy for
you to do yes is this going to take some
time and some focus it is is this going
to cause you to maybe get a little bit
uncomfortable and hit record on your
camera make a few bad videos at first it
will but as you start small it begins to
compound over time because youtube is a
content library and it's the second
largest search engine in the world
but one of my favorite things
is that youtube is free
so when i think about it as a marketing
channel it's an opportunity to get on
there that's only waiting for us on the
other side of our blood sweat and tears
right i'm just putting a little time
into it because the platform is free
this actually
makes me think of uh it reminds me of my
grandfather lowell reed when i think
about the power of youtube and it being
free
my grandpa lowell was
in the army air corps which eventually
became the air force
and he was a pilot and an instructor
and
he would instruct other pilots on flying
bombers and army fighters and actually
he met his wife my grandma martha she
was a mechanic and she would help build
these planes and then fly them to army
airports
and after their service
they
moved to edmonds washington near seattle
and he became a dentist and started a
dental practice
and i often think about the modern
marketing marketing opportunities of
today and compared to what how you would
market your business even a few years
ago and and what it takes him as an
entrepreneur to build your business and
the time and the energy and the stress
and the weight and the things that you
carry and i carry myself right
and
unfortunately both my grandfather and
grandmother have passed on
and and they missed the opportunity to
see my business grow over the last
decade start and grow and to meet my son
sean bradley but i often times uh think
of a conversation that
someday we'll have in heaven over coffee
and i'm so grateful for my grandfather
because he taught me so many things like
the value of work ethic and honor and
integrity and building your life on the
word of god and i imagine us having this
conversation
and just sitting down and him saying
sean you know
tell me about your life what are you
guys up to and i'll say oh grandpa you
know we have a son now he's 15 months
old he's absolutely a lunatic
uh and uh and actually we have another
one on the way i don't know how that
happened
i mean actually i do know how that
happened but we don't need to talk about
i don't know if you're allowed to talk
about that in heaven and uh and
and we'll be talking and they'll say
well tell me about your business i'll
say well grandpa you know i uh i started
a business i started uploading videos on
youtube actually reviewing tech
and and i actually
do youtube and i teach youtube marketing
it would be like oh what's youtube i say
oh it's kind of like tv but you take the
shows
and you put them on the internet and
people can watch them whenever they want
and he'd be like oh it's so that's so
cool
man
tell me how many people watch your
youtube
and i'd say oh grandpa about about 3 500
people
and he'd say
wow 3 500 people a year
i'd say
no grandpa about about 3 500 people
every hour
24 hours a day
and then at that moment he'd go this is
crazy are you serious
how much sean
to reach all those people
with that message did you have to
get studio time did you have to get
fancy like you know a million dollars of
equipment that is so amazing how much
did it cost sean
and i would say grandpa um
it's free
and at that moment
my known to be gentle
god-fearing and very kind grandpa i have
a feeling
would spit his coffee out
and punch me in the face
i don't know if you're allowed to punch
people in heaven but i promise you in
reaction putting in perspective the
reality of youtube that he said what are
you talk in my day come on you know you
love certain sentences that way in my
day talking to the younger generation i
had to put radio ads out i had to spend
my hard-earned money hard-earned money
on billboards i had to create referral
services and all of that stuff's amazing
but the reason i share that is to say
not that youtube's going to be easy but
that the opportunity is real and it's
waiting for you on the other side of
punching fear in the face punching
perfectionism in the face not making any
excuses why you're too busy or you can't
do it and just choosing to press
record
and so 10 years ago
i
really discovered this power of youtube
when my wife and i hit the hardest
season of our life
2007 i started dabbing on youtube from
my local church but at that time we were
in over 700 000 in debt medical bills
piling up we were losing our home and i
started posting videos on youtube and
now fast forward to today it's been
crazy because small town kid shooting
videos in my bedroom over two million
subscribers which is insane and i know
that that doesn't help you
but the reason i share that is because
it's not about two million you don't
need two you need 200 new people in your
business you need 20 right and so the
opportunity is real as you just started
and now my mission is to help people
build their influence with youtube wrote
a book called youtube secrets have had
the opportunity to work with crazy
brands like canon or amazon or western
digital and been able to get press in
media
which is a really good way to build your
authority that can happen in response to
the content you create
being featured have now built a business
of about 20 people were based in las
vegas and seattle and i'm most proud
that we've been able to help so many
students start youtube channels grow
them and reach their goals when it comes
to leveraging this powerful platform and
it's super powerful and i think that's
why many of the most consistently
influential entrepreneurs we see online
today really use youtube whether that's
a gary vaynerchuk or a lewis house or a
brenner burchard or grant cardone but i
want you to meet larry
larry is a charter chartered financial
analyst
and
he uh posted his first youtube video on
june 9th 2021
and you can kind of see that what larry
has going on here there's no fancy
studio it's just an office maybe like
yours a home office maybe like yours
no special lighting he just uses his
smartphone
and he begins to deliver valuable
information
one of the questions i get all the time
is sean is it too late to start youtube
like i mean youtube's about 16 years old
now it just got its driver's license and
like i can i still hook my wagon to this
train and the answer is yes because
literally just posting his first video
since that time in the last six months
he's grown 53 000 subscribers 900 000
views and he's only posted 13 videos but
friends it's because he was posting the
right videos
and my encouragement for you
is that what if you got 10 of those
results honestly what if you got one
percent of those results that's
practical
whether you're in the back how am i
people in the back doing whether you're
in the front like all across this room
that is practical for you to start
reaching individuals with your content
so let's just quickly talk about three
reasons why youtube rocks for financial
services specifically the first one
is traffic and leads
and when i think about traffic that's
that's viewership awareness people
discovering you that didn't know you
reaching prospects and so here's a
question what would it be worth to you
to be able to get in front of 3 500
potential clients
to book out a local hotel ballroom and
do an event right invite people to
answer their questions help them with
their retirement and have
the room packed out with 3 500 people
as i mentioned
earlier on my channel think media we are
getting 3 500 views every 60 minutes
it's like i am right now at this moment
actually getting to hang out with you at
this really cool event
and at the same time i have duplicated
myself
i it's like cl it's my clone army of
sean robots that are on the internet
doing 3 500 sales calls that are doing 3
500 meetings and i'm able to talk to
people at scale using the power of the
youtube algorithm
now again let's just take that down to
10 350 people one percent 35 people
every hour let's take it to one day 35
people a day watch your content friends
on the other side of implementing this
information we're about to learn you'll
be able to do this
all of us can
because it's super practical
when uh to lean into the power of
creating the right videos i think about
this example from centennial advisors
right
and this video is retirement advisor
gives advice
431 views very cool and that's that's
super impr i mean 43 is amazing by the
way
four is great because i know your your
thoughts you're like well you know these
channels are established i don't know no
you can do this and brick by brick like
compound interest like just investing a
little bit of your time one video at a
time
you could do this but when it comes to
traffic and leads
as centennial advisors building trust
building a relationship
then there's the opportunity for
linking to your website on the channel
someone's getting to know you they see
you they can go to your website
even more powerful in the youtube
description a good tactical place to
take notes
in the youtube description you want to
make sure you have
it make it really easy for people to
call you
put your phone number there in this case
talk to mike.com
simple url you could purchase on godaddy
and redirect to your calendly
and you could do a 15-minute strategy
session
so now a youtube video simple youtube
video
is connected to generating leads in your
business
and link to your website link to a place
to sign up to schedule consult with you
share your p your phone number with
people
but secondly the second reason youtube
rocks
is trust
you know
with all this new
business stuff the tick tocks the reels
you know what am i supposed to do next
linkedin marketing and now this guy's
talking about youtube all the way from
seattle what's going on and and
in all this new marketing stuff
business hasn't changed much right we
still do business with people we know
like and trust
and at the end of the day
we're just talking about whether a
pandemic shuts down our event and last
year we have to be at advisors excel on
digital or on virtual and shout out to
those watching virtual appreciate you so
much
at the end of the day it's about this
we got to connect man we got to rub
shoulders we got to hang out tonight and
listen to some entertainment and eat
some food
and and toast to what you've been
achieving and the success you've been
building but it's about know like and
trust and what i love about youtube is
it's an accelerator
in fact it's an automator
of trust building
because as you create youtube videos you
now are getting discovered on youtube
people are watching and getting to know
you but here's a tip
share really valuable information in
your videos
but also include your values
include a little antidote of of your
story who you are what matters to you
because we actually do business with
people more that have shared beliefs
rather than ju
just
the service they could provide for us
it's called values matching we want to
do business with people that have our
shared beliefs and so as they get to
know you then they have to they can
decide if they get to like you but
here's the cool thing about them
watching you on youtube they watch your
video and they go i don't like that
person
right
no problem you don't even know like that
they're just watching the video they're
they're pre-determining
if if they want to go to a deeper level
when they're ready they can pick up the
phone when they're ready as they watch
your information and so it accelerates
this and this is fascinating to me
because this is what we're up against in
2022 when it comes to marketing
a recent report said it takes 18 touches
on average to get a response from a
prospect
don't ever get discouraged if you think
man
like i'm i'm putting out content or i've
i've got some leads i've got some people
that have reached out but i just i'm
calling them they're not answering the
phone i'm emailing them they're not
opening the emails it's it's i'm having
trouble getting are they ignoring me do
they not want my help anymore erase that
from your mentality in 2022. what 2022
is is life is so busy a grandkid just
came into their office and kicked a cup
of coffee onto their crotch and now it's
scalding hot and they can't you know
there there's so many different
distractions and there's so much
different messaging coming at them it
takes at least 18 touches
to get a response from a prospect
thus
by having your youtube content out there
embracing social media each of these
things can be touch points and then when
you send your email newsletter
with your just valuable youtube video
they go oh that's right i did want to
make that next decision in my finances
be encouraged to just keep going at it
from multiple angles in terms of
marketing and touches in order to reach
that desired goal
so a power tip is posting valuable
content on youtube builds relationships
with potential clients and customers in
a non-sales situation
on youtube what's your strategy you're
adding free valuable content we're going
to talk about the five specific videos
in just a second but you're adding free
valuable content people just getting to
know you they can decide if they want to
do business with you they can decide if
they vibe with you they hear a little
bit of story or they hear how you
connect a lesson you've learned in your
life
to
the power of them investing with you or
signing up for an annuity with you or
whatever life insurance and just just
getting to know people in a non-sales
situation now sales
really becomes a lot less hard the sales
done by the time they call
because it's it's a very powerful
trust builder on youtube but number
three is authority positioning no
authority positioning this is why i hope
that by the end of this talk and at the
end of this conference that you have
dreams at night about me
worded wrong don't tell my wife i said
that i hope
that by the end of this i actually do i
want you to have dreams at night about
youtube like man i got to start that
youtube channel like i i could see the
power of that i got to start my youtube
channel i got to commit to this and and
the reason is authority positioning i
think about casey who does retire with
purpose
and i think about the authority
positioning
of having a youtube channel especially
you're talking to gen x baby boomers
think about
comparing two different financial
advisors one has a youtube channel is
building their brand building their
personal brand online
the other has not done that who has more
just kind of authority and perceived
authority it's the person with the
youtube channel you have your own media
company you have your own tv station you
have your own youtube chat it's an
authority
builder to be positioned online on these
platforms and it reminds me of this
quote from brian tracy that says the top
20 percent of sales people earn on
average 16 times more
than the bottom 80 percent
which makes me just say well how do i
just get into the top 20 percent and
stay in the top 20 percent what are some
things i can do to position myself
position my brand and my company brand
my business brand in that top 20
16x multiplier
i am actually standing on stage not good
at math but you are and so you could
probably multiply that to what results
you're getting right now that is the
authority effect
of stepping into youtube
and posting content and so here's
youtube 101 for financial services let's
recap what we've learned so far
number one
step one is get views we'll talk about
how to do that in a second but you post
some content on youtube and you want to
get some views
sean what value are views to me can i
take views to the bank and invest it no
you can't and so we have to go somewhere
from there but that's where it's going
to start i want to get views on my i
want to get 40 views on my video
six views on my video i want to start
getting views and remember it will grow
as you post more and more videos because
that's how the youtube algorithm works
step two
is get leads
now that as your you've also
intelligently connected your website
phone number text message line whatever
marketing channels you want to use
get leads
and then repeat the process
that's what it is
that is the
basic three-step formula
for what you want to achieve with
youtube in terms of growing your
business
and as you activate the compound
interest multiplier authority building
trust building effect of youtube it just
continues to grow over time and then
what happens imagine this think about my
circumstance with 3 500 views an hour
when i'm not posting new videos
with the right structure in place your
website a way to capture people's
information when they're ready
youtube is working for you when you're
not working
youtube is like a sales team for you
when you're not working because views
are people are discovering your content
and then coming into your world
through the power of youtube but sean so
i hear but you're like okay
i would hope by this time you're like i
get it sounds good but but sean
i'm just not a video person like i don't
know i don't know if i want to get on
camera
like i i don't know what to say
i i
that i might just have the deer in the
headlights look um you know my easy for
you to say you've been doing this for a
while i feel like i'm late to the game i
got so many other things to do
i'm convinced i should do youtube but
like i just don't know what if i put out
some bad videos like what if i put out
videos and actually lose credibility
because i stumble over my my words what
if i just don't you know articulate
clearly or put out great content when i
start and i'm glad you asked that
because i happen to just have a little
clip of the first video that i posted on
youtube let's just check this out to see
my first video here
all right so uh this is i guess the
first sean thanks vlog and i'm gonna try
to vlog
every single day
mainly so i can remember what i'm even
doing um and what's going on because i
just feel like i have a lot that i'm
thinking about and i figured hey why not
share it and if you find something
interesting that's awesome now this is
definitely as real as it gets so i'm not
going to try to be
energetic or entertaining
though maybe sometimes
i will
but anyways uh
i promise you your first video could be
better than this first video right
and and by the way you want some more
tips there's a couple tips in there tip
number one if you have a white sheet
background for your first video actually
put it up like what was i thinking like
day one like i'm ready i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna put my first video out i got
my background i need to put the
background up
you know if you another approach uh if
you're gonna make your first video i i
say um i don't even know what i'm gonna
talk about or what i'm gonna do here's a
tip
have an idea of what you're gonna talk
about in your first video like just pick
something like i'm gonna talk about
401ks and taxes you know and then and
then i have two other anti strategies
i'm gonna plan on being
not energetic and not entertaining so i
mean i accomplished like the four
cardinal sins of like making the worst
youtube video of all time but here's the
reason why this is powerful is because
i'm so glad i posted this because if i
wouldn't have posted a bad video i
wouldn't have ever got to the good ones
like your first videos are going to be
your worst videos
you got to just start messy you got to
just start before you're ready there's
something powerful about just starting
you can't steer
a parked car
come on buckle up come on it's time to
speed up you got to just start getting
some momentum and you got to be
kind of okay with practicing in public
and sucking at the start
my friend ben always says it this way he
said the the path to success on youtube
is suck suck success
yeah
like you gotta just you gotta just start
before you're ready so are are you ready
to start on youtube can you say yes
awesome awesome so now we're starting
massey let's grab our smartphone like
larry and just deliver some value but
sean what kind of content are we going
to create here's
five smart video ideas for growing your
financial service business this is what
i would do how do i set up my channel
easy we have free videos on our channel
in fact i'll give you our free youtube
school uh at the end but uh here's five
smart video ideas for now you've got
your channel set up you just have your
gmail address the first simple video
is you're going to asq
answer specific questions
that's it
you're going to answer specific
questions
asq
65 of people use youtube to help them
solve a problem
and so looking at troy sharp's video
here
listen to the title of this video i'm 61
with 1 million in my 401k can i retire
i love it i couldn't be more in love
with this title because it's so specific
so the opportunity to make
like a generic question about 401ks
let's say
is there but where there's big
opportunity is answering specific
questions because the internet is
helping you reach people at scale
so there's a lot of people that are 61
and in this situation and this specific
video is answering that specific
question and here's the crazy thing i
don't know if you can see the number up
there
426 000 people have watched this video
now remember comparison is the thief of
joy comparison will kill your creativity
we're not comparing ourself to to troy
and we got to just start where we're at
because you're going to upload your
first video and you're going to be like
i didn't get 426 000 views
i got
two views and that was because i
refreshed two times
you got to just keep going when troy
started he got two views as well
and and you keep posting and the cool
thing about youtube is as you are
answering specific questions you build a
library of videos up video one through
five not much might happen but when the
right video hits at the right time and
you can't always predict it video 13
gets 1300 views and
sally is watching on the other side of
the uh their her computer she then goes
well that was great and starts watching
your other videos so now those start
getting more views and it becomes this
snowball effect because you're answering
specific questions this video specific
question taxes on 401k retirement
account withdrawals
really powerful and then notice there's
a just a little bar on the video some
simple video editing software or an app
on your phone
schedule your consult and then a way to
get leads as we learned right adding
some value hey you want some help go to
this url nothing special about the video
nothing special about the camera
practical video lighting tip having a
giant light actually behind you is not
the best ever but guess what it doesn't
even matter
right because meanwhile this video has
11 000 views it's also three years old
and i when i checked though a month ago
someone was still engaging with
questions on it
so what is it worth to you to post a
video three years ago in your living
room where you just share some stuff
that you already know and here's how i
like to think about youtube
just like you sit down with people over
coffee or you just sit down on zoom and
you just answer their questions
think about your most ideal client and
the person that you help
just talk to that one person
you're just there to help you're there
to serve and you deliver that value turn
the camera off upload it on youtube
and you'll be stunned by what it'll do
over time so the power question for you
to be brainstorming is what questions
are your ideal
customers asking
you right now
notice how quick this would flow for you
you like you could probably come up with
five immediately
i gave you a couple minutes you come up
with 15.
oh yeah these are the ones they're
asking the most what are the what are
the worries
what what like is keeping them up at
night what are they texting or calling
you about
what are what are they confused about
what are they just looking for clarity
on
answer specific questions so keep
brainstorming but the second one is
review specific products
now this is interesting this is how i
built my career originally because i
started doing video in 2003 for my
church 2009 i started a business doing
video production in 2010 i started to do
camera reviews and video tutorials
helping people understand cameras
content creation we're not going to talk
a ton about that today you can connect
with our free content and we will show
you any phone
any editing whatever you want to do from
beginner to advanced we have that for
you for free online
but i started to talk about
cameras and i was reviewing specific
products and earning money through
affiliate marketing and different things
like that but you might say well what
does that mean for us though i mean you
know in financial services what would we
do so i just kind of brainstormed a
couple ideas here's one
fidelity versus vanguard detailed review
in fact one of my favorite strategies
and write this down is the versus
strategy
when there's two options
this video i guarantee will get you
views if you are knowledgeable on two
options and i don't know all the ins and
outs of your business
two investment options two different
banks two different online
e-trade accounts or i don't know like
there's so many different things but
notice
this video has 367 000 views
well sean you're probably just picking
up the the top video the long tail of
this
is there's videos with a hundred
thousand views thirty thousand three
thousand three hundred thirty eight and
you gotta be grateful for the 38 because
that'll grow your business when you're
attracting the right people and when
you're optimizing your content to speak
to the exact audience you want to speak
to probably baby boomers and probably
planning for the future gen x right
here's another example how to invest in
a vanguard roth ira for beginners 2021
using i can't even see the rest of the
title
detailed
specific tips
and how to in a specific product review
specific products teach about a specific
product someone's at home trying to even
figure out how to set their account up
stuff you would think is too easy too
basic it's probably the videos you
should make because people are going to
youtube in fact baby boomers one of
their favorite things to go to youtube
seven out of ten of them are there and
they're going for nostalgia
they're going to stay abreast of current
events and they're going to learn how to
do things
and so they would prefer think with
google revealed they would actually
rather watch a video than read text
teaching them how to do things so if you
review a specific product or teach on a
specific product that could really
attract
the right audience what products
services and apps or software
i would think in our industry here are
ideal for your prospect
this is these are just ideas and you
have to do it you don't have to do any
one of these or you can do all of these
and your goal is to have like an arsenal
to choose from what do i want to choose
today on my next video i'm just going to
answer a specific question this week hey
oh cool there's that new app out that
helps people you know budget i'm going
to review that app
and the interesting thing is you want to
think outside of potentially the ae
world because you just want to reach
people what is the adjacent
conversations
because you might be talking about a
really popular app
and then you're able to share your
polarizing point of view and say yeah i
mean it's pretty cool and so on and so
forth but honestly there's about five
weaknesses with it it's this this this
and this and you know what i'm more
passionate about is this this is just an
entry point to a conversation
talking about products services apps and
software number three teach specific
skills
tss
teach
specific
skills
so casey from retire on purpose
made this video use these strategies to
mitigate your task tax risk in
retirement
so he's teaching
specific skills
video has 179 views i'm pumped about
that all day long and i'm pumped about
17 right
and so we just get on we teach specific
skills and and i want you in your notes
to circle that word specific notice it
was in all three of the first three of
the strategies again the more specific
the better because the argument in
modern marketing as well is your
competition and how saturated things are
and so you're not trying to go broad
you're actually trying to go specific
it's actually being more niche there's a
phrase in online marketing that says the
riches are in the niches
it's because when you get specific you
didn't just realize and then again you
put out 10 of those videos over the next
10 weeks
and then you look back in the next 10
months even if you stopped and you got
busy and you look back and you go oh my
gosh one of the videos that has 1 600
views now oh man all these people been
signing up for these consults they're
all coming in because i was talking
about one niche specific thing teaching
specific skills but i love this one
number four
is trend and influence surfing is it
okay if we get a little bit advanced say
yes
wow the after lunch energy just
just impacted me as 14 come on is it
okay if i go a little advanced can we
say yes
all right all right so number four
trend in influence surfing you know i
learned this when i was in oceanside
california with my former youth pastor
jeff we're surfing and he's surfing i
should say and he invited me at an
ungodly early morning hour against my
will but as a good friend i decided to
go with him with no skills whatsoever in
terms of how to surf he gets me the
biggest spongiest longboard and i go out
there i'm trying to you know
paddle out i have no upper arm strength
as you can see and i'm trying to paddle
out and i you know my arms are already
tired turn around try to catch waves i'm
getting tumbled in the waves salt water
in my eyes my eyes are burning i'm
thinking what a great friend you are
jeff this is an amazing morning i really
appreciate you bro so that's where i was
at but the lesson i learned about
youtube was i was watching him and he's
like a pro surfer
and he has this short board and he goes
out a couple times a week and he's on
the surfboard and he'd go out he'd find
a certain wave he'd pop up he'd sit on
his board
right
and and then he would look and he would
watch
for what waves are coming to pick the
right one
and then eventually he would see because
he wouldn't go after just any
wave
he would look for a specific one and
then he would start paddling and he
would start paddling and then he'd pop
up and like a pro surfer he'd write it
resentment just began to mount in my
soul towards him as i was watching him
you know riding the waves and uh and i
ended our friendship but i mean just
kidding right but but uh but what i
learned was just the power of of trend
surfing and influence surfing and what
that means is that if you really want to
master modern marketing as well as
really thrive on youtube this is one of
the most powerful ways to do it but it's
going to take
wisdom it's going to take
tact it's going to
maybe or maybe not fit with your
personality but i'll explain and show
you what i mean
here's a couple examples of influence
surfing
you're asking yourself who has influence
that i can
share my point of view on or react to
and these are some powerful video titles
one don't listen to dave ramsey
there's something one of the most
powerful things you could do in modern
marketing is have a polarizing point of
view
now i know you might go wow i don't know
if i could step into that and this might
not be for you but you also there's a
way to do this where you might say
dave ramsey says this is that true and
then you're able to present your case
see chances are more people know dave
ramsey than you
right and so the power of influence
surfing or
more people know joe biden than you
and so biden's secret tax plan explained
the thing when it comes to
influence surfing is you're trying to
make youtube videos and stand out in a
sea of sameness
on youtube how do you do it using this
very powerful strategy called trend
surfing and influence surfing
and so
here's another one
how will inflation affect 401ks or how
will inflation affect 401k should we
hold
you got to be aware
of the things that are keeping your
prospects up at night
inflation becomes these become actual
google trends the search volume of
certain words at certain times
skyrockets and so
who are people talking about in the
media
what book or concept or ideology or
framework was just released
what and here's where you really find
your passion on this you have your
convictions about financial financial
services and there are different
approaches in different ideologies
and when someone says something you go
oh man it got me fired up that's not
true that you shouldn't do that that's
not the right vehicle for investing
that's not the right way to go you
better hit that's a good time to hit
record and you go listen a lot of people
are talking about this thing
but here's actually the truth they
haven't considered this they haven't
considered this they haven't considered
this and you are surfing like my friend
jeff
the trend you're surfing the way because
youtube will come in waves that's how
youtube works
and videos will be recommended by the
algorithm maybe talking or reacting to a
certain situation a certain court ruling
a certain individual and so if you want
to have some jet fuel if you really want
to buckle up and and speed up the growth
of your business and your youtube
channel leveraging this strategy is
incredibly powerful
maybe everyone's talking about heloc's
versus home equity loans etc and again
remember you shouldn't create videos
just directly related to what you're
doing you should be creating videos
about the whole orbit
of concepts and topics that your ideal
prospect is considering doing
so
i it is my belief that none of you are
helping with home equity lines of credit
but you probably have some tips about it
and people that are thinking about that
meet you
and they get to know like and trust you
and get to hear about the other stuff
that you're doing by leveraging trend
surfing and influence surfing if you can
do it in a tactful you can do it any way
you want but but ultimately it's a very
powerful strategy to integrate into your
content to create hyper growth on your
channel but number five as we land the
plane
is start a video podcast
this would be i think the most powerful
i would recommend everybody in here
at some point in 2022
start a video podcast
and the idea here is is starting a show
now i know this could feel intimidating
look at this you know
cool woman with headphones and this mic
what mic do i get what headphones do i
get wow look at her cool office
no that's not what matters but i know
there's a million tech questions and
i'll share some resources to help you
but look all you need
is is you can start a show on zoom
and starting a show the key here is not
just a podcast but a video podcast so i
love what casey's doing here
he's doing an interview show 52 minutes
too uploading high impact transition
into your third act
bringing on guests who could you
interview who could you have come on
and so watch this we're going to go fast
you then record an interview
with an expert an author or you just do
a solo round where you say today seven
things you can should consider for
retirement you talk for 30 minutes you
start it you turn it off you're good to
go and you post it on youtube
then you have the opportunity to also
post that audio on podcast platforms
so it's a video podcast
then you also have that opportunity to
embed that that audio file into your
website onto your website's blog
so now you're taking
one
piece of content that you're investing
your energy into
and you're sitting down doing an
interview doing your video podcast but
you're using it in multiple places but
the rabbit hole's about to get a lot
deeper because we've posted it on
youtube we've posted on the audio
platforms we posted on our website but
we're just going to look at the video
podcast content pyramid
the next thing we can do now is we could
do short catchy clips
now at this point we've just gone into
the deep end of advanced
and what i'm showing you here is to
paint a trajectory
of what's possible because listen more
money is going to come in
there's going to be more resource to
what i would eventually encourage that
you hire help and you hire a team or you
work with resources around you that
could help you cut out short catchy
clips if you know joe rogan he has a
large podcast but multiple clips come
out of each show and every single one of
those clips has the chance to read reach
people related to headlines you do a
news video podcast you talk about five
things all five of the things you talk
about in the 30 minutes could also all
be five minute clips and those short
catchy clips can also be posted on
youtube as well so your long show is
there later in the week something else
is there sounds like a lot of work yeah
but so much money is coming in now you
have an assistant helping you and
they're helping you distribute this
content you could do things like
expanding on social media turning your
video podcast into an instagram carousel
turning the video podcast into blogs and
linkedin articles and here's ultimately
the pyramid to take a screenshot of you
create one youtube video that you embed
on your website
the audio goes on pod class
platforms
short clips come out of that that can be
posted on youtube and social media
and then even that can be repurposed
transcribed and put into articles quote
cards and blog posts
there's services that do this there's
ways that you could approach doing this
you could dabble in doing it yourself
you make one show a week and then
distribute it
throughout the week but here's what i
want to encourage you
is that you got to just start messy
and you complexity is the enemy of
execution i don't recommend tomorrow
especially after the party tonight that
you try to build out your entire content
pyramid right that's how you might be
feeling but listen
the there's never been a better time to
just get started
because ultimately the best time to
plant a tree was 20 years ago right
when's the second best time to plant a
tree today and so this the best time to
start a youtube channel was 16 years ago
and to kind of ramp into it and make
some really bad videos like i made but
the second best time to do it is today
and so
this was just the tip of the iceberg as
we land the plane i know you might have
a million other questions right okay i
get it i'd love to do this and sean i'd
i'd love more help whether that's on
video creation or confidence or
thumbnails or all that kind of stuff i
have something really cool that myself
and the think media team have created
entirely free it's called
freeyoutubeschool.com
and it's just a resource that'll
actually answer specific questions all
the way through it'll actually just lead
you to youtube videos and resources that
we have there's other ways you can work
with us but but legitimately this is all
you need to get started and start
getting momentum on your youtube channel
if you want these slides i'm happy to
send them to you just shoot me an email
and i would love to get these in your
hands but i want you to picture a day
when you have endless leads coming to
you
even though you took summer off and you
stopped creating youtube content in any
kind of content altogether
i actually want you to picture a day
when you sit down for coffee with
somebody sit down with coffee cup to
coffee with somebody and they go this is
so weird because
i already watched like i listen to your
video podcast i feel like i know you
better than my husband you know they're
literally like i've spent 80 hours with
you over the last couple years listening
to you it's so great to meet you in
person when they're finally ready to
take action
and sign up and work with you
and picture a day when you actually
again have enough money coming in that
you can scale this and automate this as
you're able to hire more people or
reinvest in your business that's all
possible friends and it's waiting for
you on the other side of punching fear
in the face punching perfectionism in
the face and pressing record
thank you
well i hope that brought insight to the
business owners that are interested in
learning how to grow their youtube
channel it is incredible to me that so
many people who are running businesses
and paying for marketing don't actually
see the power of how they can go
directly to the person who needs what
they have to offer people are going to
youtube right now today as you're
listening to this podcast searching for
answers and you business owner can be
the answer on the other side of youtube
the other part that youtube can bring to
you is building your personal brand as a
business owner as someone who wants to
get more clients or grow your
customer base building your personal
brand could be the key to unlocking to
the next level in your business so many
business owners should be focused in
this year on growing your personal brand
and one way that you can do that is by
joining us at grow with video live 2022.
this will be the number one conference
for entrepreneurs who want to grow their
personal brand with video not just
youtube but tik tok instagram linkedin
really understanding how current
business owners like garyvee
patrickbetdavid ijustine and alex or
mozy are growing their brands using
video they're gonna be at growth video
live this year and we're gonna have not
just day one and day two with a plethora
of speakers for you to learn from but we
are also going to be offering a platinum
experience so if you want more
information about attending growth video
live or what that platinum experience
could be for you business owner then you
definitely want to go to
growethvideolive.com right now and you
can see all of the options available to
you
this is going to be an amazing
experience that you do not want to miss
being in the room with people like this
that are growing personal brands on
these different platforms is going to be
something that you'll want to take
advantage of not just today but for the
years to come i believe that with you
building your personal brand you will be
able to go further faster online you
want to be known you want to make sure
that people know who you are
so that when you have something to sell
they can buy it well thank you so much
for being a part of today's episode and
i want to say if you've not yet rated or
reviewed the podcast you can do that
over on apple podcast and today
today's review comes from
cam and cam says great podcasts love all
the advice and tips to build your brand
this is a must listen well cam i hope
that you're going to be at growth video
live 2022 this year as well joining us
in person so that we can help you grow
your brand live in person thank you so
much for listening and make sure you
subscribe wherever you are listening on
and we'll catch you next tuesday for the
think media podcast bye did you hear
that growth video live 2022 is back in
person this is your opportunity to
network with like-minded people just
like you to make friendships to make
business partnerships this is your
opportunity to get in the room you can
get your ticket now at
growethvideolive.com they're going so
fast so make sure you get your ticket
right now at growthvideolive.com
you